[Music]
welcome back to Hannity's we continue
from Vegas and joining us now Fox News
contributor Tommy Lehren recording
artists she was on stage an hour before
this all happened kya Jones is with us
you know all these celebrities
Hollywood's lab responds didn't bodies
for an even cold okay and I understand
we should have a passionate debate I
laid out some facts tonight here's the
thing most of those people live in big
fat gated communities they have security
systems that are the envy of the world
they go out in public and they have
bodyguards some arms some not Jimmy
Kimmel I'm sure has how many security
guards in the studio every night I'll
take a bet on that
you know in case Oh somebody rushes the
stage or in the taping and I'm like what
about the rest of the country that wants
to protect themselves in an evil and
dangerous world
it feels empowered with a firearm
there's able to protect themselves now
they're saying well this situation they
wouldn't have been able to protect
themselves this is one situation what
about the hundreds that happen every
single day we're someone with a gun a
good guy with a gun that's trained
stopped a situation I know for when I
feel much more safe when I have someone
that's ex-military ex-police officer
around me with a firearm I feel much
more safe and secure no go zone or a
shooting breaks a San Bernardino they
dropped the clip and reloaded that's
called an opportunity to save lives
100% I don't understand how less guns
equate less Mad Men okay it doesn't and
that's the argument the constant
argument is about weapons weapons
weapons is about guns legislation all of
us people just died this is my hometown
Tommy went to UNLV
you know Kimmel if you're from Vegas
where are you coach where are you shot
where are you and his father was here
less I got shot in the chest the UNLV
hockey coach here's my question to them
somebody god forbid breaks into your
house yeah you have your wife you have
your kids you have a girlfriend you have
whoever's there okay they break in
they're armed by their very nature
criminals don't obey laws my question is
that what are you going to do to protect
your family
and beyond that you and I both know this
but to those out there that want to
lecture us on on gun sense gun safety if
someone's gonna go to the 32nd floor of
a hotel and they're they're hell-bent on
murdering thousands of people do you
really think they're gonna be like well
you know the law says I can't have this
weapon the law says I shouldn't have
this many guns is this compound that's
like napalm this guy had it so there if
you have evil intentions in your heart
you'll find a way you're gonna find a
way we use explosives that's the thing
with these celebrities that are talking
ariana grande look what happened at her
concert another tragedy explosives
they're going to find a way look what
happened in Boston SAR no criminals
terrorists psychos they don't obey our
laws they don't care about your gun
control and if anything when you have a
gun-free zone you're neutering everyone
they're the people if they're watching
they hate our opinion what is the net
result okay we're going to have this
check or that check this guy got checked
you know it look if we can improve the
system so mentally ill people don't get
to hold the guns I'm open for
improvements that are common sense but
also support our constitutional rights
for law-abiding citizens to protect
themselves and their family because
eventually they're going to find other
ways to kill us they're fine men we're
seeing it in Europe oh they'll use a car
or a box cutter yeah or a bomb
although strap oh they'll build the gun
or some best that's right
there's no I mean this is not a time to
rhetoric scream politics politics
politics the day after it happened it
began politics about the gun I've
carried a gun my entire adult life I
feel better with a gun in my life yeah
period here's my question though
why are we spending all this time not us
but others in the news and others in the
celebrity sphere why are they spending
all their time analyzing what kind of
guns he use how many he had I want to
know more about him to be honest I want
to know more about his girlfriend I want
to know about the victims I want to know
about their families as don't you find
there's something off here whether
there's fire normally when these
incidents happen you know everything
about the person you know every Facebook
page that I've ever been on every post
they've ever made
every one that they've ever known every
one they went to high school with and
now all of a sudden all we're talking
about is the the weapons that he use and
the firearms he use now something stinks
I know this is both your hometowns our
thoughts and prayers would with all of
your friends that live here and all the
trauma they suffer son you're here
you're handling it you know you're doing
a great thing for this nation you know
what we've got to pray for these
families your biggest suffering we need
it we need prayers right now all right
that's all the time we have